You're about to watch a conversation
between me and Alexi Omar, who's a legal
attorney for musicians. The problem is
that he's losing money and lots of it.
And he only has about 6 months of cash
left before his dream is going to go
under. My name's Alexi acquisition.com.
It's a portfolio of companies that last
year did over $250 million in aggregate
revenue. And we're going to take all of
those findings and help him save his
business. Enjoy. Let's do a quick quick
overview. So, walk me through the
business as it currently stands right
now. What's revenue? Our revenue over
the last 12 months has been 300,000
profit. Uh negative. So we're losing
money. Okay. How much? We lost a
100,000. Okay. Minus 100,000. Yes.
You're like, I could have done nothing
and I would have just had zero at the
end of the year instead of working all
year and then being worse off. Heard.
All right. What are the business units
right now? We have services. Okay. We
have education. Okay. And who do you
sell to? I I sell to artists and
entrepreneurs in the Latin music
industry. Musicians who are Latin
American who speak Spanish. Yeah. Okay.
And uh you sell service, you sell
education, what was the last one?
Software. What's the revenue breakdown
between Did any of these make money?
Yeah. This the services. So this made
money was profitable. Yeah, that was
profitable. Okay. What was the top line
and bottom line here? So we
made 131,000. Okay. And we made about
10k for the in the last 10 uh 12 months
in profit on that because you just
didn't lose money on this one basically.
Okay. And then education
131 as well. Oh, how coincidental. All
right. Profit. But we lost there like
most of the money we lost between the
two. Okay. So it's between the two
because they're under one company. Got
it. And so this is 40K. I'm just going
to put this as for the software. And
then the money that you lost here was
how much in total? I guess 100 110,000.
Mhm. Okay. Put a little negative smiley
face there. Maybe a little tears. There
we go. Very sad. Okay. More tears. Yeah.
More tears. All right. So, how are you
how are you getting customers right now
before we talk about how we're going to
fix this? How you getting customers? So,
we create content on YouTube. We have
about 90,000 subscribers. Is that where
most like everybody's coming from? Yeah.
Okay. So, we got got YouTube. All right.
What else we got? Then they usually go
to our Instagram page from YouTube.
Yeah. Okay. Is that the that's like the
call to action in the videos and like
the call to action is to go to our
website, but a lot of people go to
Instagram to just uh ask questions like,
"Hey, I have this problem. Can you help
me?" Interesting. Okay, got it. So,
where do the sales come from then? The
sales comes through DMs. So, usually
they go to Instagram and they'll ask a
question. So, the place that you don't
intend people to go is where you make
your money. Yeah. Instagram. And you
don't tell people to go there. They just
find you. Instagram? No. Yeah. They just
find us. Okay. All right. We'll put a
little star next to that. If all the
money is coming in from Instagram, how
many DMs do you get? So, we don't have
that number. We know that from the
website, we generate about 7,000 uh
visitors. Okay. And for example, in
April, we made 150 leads this far. So
7,000 clicks. Got it. All right. And
then that goes into 150. Okay. Got it.
So you're converting 2%. Okay. Into
optins. Yeah. They're for free course.
Okay. Optin for a free course. Yeah. Got
it. Okay. And then from there, and then
from there, usually we'll try to sell
them the course, our main course. How do
you try and sell them? Do you like reach
out to them? Do you What do you With
every video, we usually tell them, hey,
and if you want to learn more about
this, make sure to to enroll in our
community. Mhm. The next step for that,
they'll go through the course and
receive some nurturing emails. And then
from the emails is how they buy. And
what are they buying from the emails?
So, right now we're selling about um
nine nine out of the 150. Our basic
offer is $500 onetime fee. So, they have
access to all of our courses now and
forever. Okay. And then we have an
upsell of another 500 to is that on a
funnel or something? Yeah. In the same
cart. Okay. Where they when they buy the
500, we'll upsell them to another 500
for monthly Q&A per month. No, just
lifetime as well. Forever. Yeah. Nice.
Okay. Oh gosh. Okay. So, there's so many
I mean, where do There's so many things.
Before we, you know, tear this apart,
the good news is uh I actually think
that you'll be able to make
significantly more money pretty quickly.
So, this is your education side. Yeah.
All right. What's the uh services side?
So, on the same Instagram page, if they
want a consultation instead of learning
because they say, "I'm not interested in
learning. Sure. I just want Okay. I want
you to do it. Yeah. I want you to do it.
We'll then send them to our Calendarly
link. Okay. To schedule a consultation
and that's
$250 for an hour. So you go DM to
calendar. Mhm. Okay. And then you charge
before you have the call. Yeah, man.
Okay. Okay. 250. Dude, the good news is
there's lots of room for improvement.
Okay. That's great. So you have your
calendar and then you charge 250 per
hour and they pay on the calendar to to
have access. Yes, man. All right. And so
that means that you sold somewhere in
the neighborhood of uh 6 or 630
something like whatever the math is 131*
4 that's 400 520. So uh 524 so 524 hours
is what you were able to sell in
services last year. You could 131,000.
Okay. between the consultations because
usually when they go through the
consultation say for example the in the
last three months we've averaged about
nine to 10 calls. Mhm. So then from
there we we'll either tell them do you
need a deliverable service? So for
example registering your trademark or
business information. Those are three
out of the 10 you can say. And then uh
another three are ongoing legal
services. Okay. And what other business
do you have? Let's talk about that. So
the other business is the software cuz
you're like you know I'm not losing
money so I should uh I am losing money.
Excuse me. So I'm going to I'm going to
spread my attention even more. Yeah.
Okay. So So we're like story behind
that. I know. I know. I know. It's a VC
story. So, if you want a horror story, I
can give you that. We We'll get We'll
get We'll get into it, I'm sure. All
right. So, there's a software company.
Okay. So, let's walk through that. So,
the software is Instagram. Where's the
same thing? Um, usually they'll say, "I
don't have
$250. I just want contracts." Um, okay.
Okay. And we'll tell them, well, you can
access, you know, all of our contract
templates inside our software, so you
can pay for that. Okay? And that's what
happens. Right now, we're so via
Instagram, you just send those people a
not a calendar link and you don't send
them to the site, you send them to to
our to our software website. So, which
is a different website. And then they
just check out on that page. They start
a free. We had a premium, now we're
using free trial. Okay. Um, and what's
the membership price right now? It's
a,000 per year. And that's what So it
goes straight to a,000 per year is what
you were billing. Yes. We also have a
monthly version. They were like, I can't
afford $250. And you were like, yeah, so
pay $1,000 a year. Before we have a $500
per year. Yeah. So it was easier. The
problem is that the value proposition at
first was, well, pay us and we give you
the contracts. But learning that people
were churning because once they have the
contract they'll download it and just go
away. We have a couple of decisions that
we have to make. Is there any reason
that you just don't sell services and
make money? Sales. Well, the reality is
we started selling services in back in
2019. So in 2021, uh people we got a lot
of demand. I couldn't keep up. I started
selling courses so they could you know
learn about how to do them themselves.
And then after that um and also contract
templates and then the education side
just you know we started making the same
amount of money on education. This is
going to be an important one for you.
Yeah. All right. So actually you know
what I'm going to show you on my logo.
Two most important concepts in business
supply and demand and leverage. So if
supply is low and demand is high what
happens to price? It it goes up. Is that
what happened? Yeah we started doing
that. Yes. But then you created this
other thing that was much cheaper rather
than just saying I don't have enough
supply. Pay me more. You're right. All
right. We wanted to help more people
instead of just Yeah. But the thing is
is that a long enough time horizon and
you'll have no one if we don't make this
business profitable. Mhm. Right. Yes. So
okay, tell me why we can't shut down the
education and software so that we can
just do services and then we can fix the
service business to make it make money.
Yeah. So the educational side, we
already have over 800 people. They all
bought like lifetime everything.
Lifetime everything. Lifetime
everything. The thing with with the
education is that it's part of we are
giving back to the community and nobody
else is doing this. All right. So every
time thanks to the education efforts, we
are traveling the world and teaching
other people in Guatemala, in the
Dominican Republic, in Spain how the
music business works because in those
places our content is the university's
content. So it's it's an impact project
right. Okay. So that is why the
education you know it would be very
difficult for us to shut down and the
education without the software is not
losing money. It's the software that
that actually Okay. So when we did this
breakdown how you said the education
loses money. So how much money does the
education make if you don't have the
software? In reality the education would
be a break even. Okay. That the that
whole money that we're losing is zero.
Yeah. But but you said this is 110,000
of losses. So that means the software
costs you 150,000 a year and makes you
40. Yes. Okay. You could say that. So
why can't we be done with the software?
So the software right now there's not a
specific reason we can't shut it down.
We we've seen traction on the B2B side
of companies in the music industry that
are interested in using our software
because their clients like big companies
now need a music contract software to
manage their documents. So the play
there for us. So what the software the
software but that is something that how
much did it cost you to develop the
software? Right now it's burning 7K a
month because we
cut every every you know every employee
before. How likely is it do you think
that you're going to sell the software?
I'm not sure. And the other thing is the
software actually right now the way we
are seeing it grow is by bundling
services with software. Well it's
obvious that the service is the thing
that everyone needs. Yes. Yes. And then
we just have like this other stuff that
we did to be cute. Where do you want to
grow from here? What do you want to have
happen? The thing that we need is to be
profitable. Okay. That we can solve very
easily. That's the good news. Yeah. But
it will just be painful. Yeah. But it's
good pain. Growing pains. Yeah. Call
them growing pains. If you lose a
negative, it's a positive. So, okay. So
in a world hypothetically where you just
ended the software tomorrow and then you
have the education and services what is
required for you to maintain the
education work-wise per week. Right now
it's only one live stream with the
community per month or per month. Yeah,
that's the only thing. That's it. Okay,
great. Can we just shut down the
software? We can do that. Wow, that was
easy. Okay, great. I love this for us.
Okay. So, we're gonna X this out. Let's
use a red. Let's keep this, you know,
keep this keep this on brand here. So,
this is a red. I'm gonna say that this
isn't really a business. I'm going to
say this is a charity. You might even
want to operate like a nonprofit because
it doesn't make any profit anyways and
you're you're very, you know, kind of
impact driven and whatnot. So, then
what's the cost on the 131,000 in
services? The cost would be the
associate who is delivering the
services. Okay. Right now we have a
revshare model. Okay. But we also have
because the services for example this
year we are already at 150k.
Okay. Great. Because now thanks to the
education um the next generation of
artists are looking towards us to
represent them in deal closing closing
deals. Right. Okay. So from there we
take a commission from the deal. Okay.
So, for example, uh we've recently
closed uh several deals that are above
500,000 for the artist. Amazing. And we
take 5% from those. Okay. So, do you
guys act as an agent for that? They're
No, they're lawyers representative.
Those are legal fees that the label uh
will also pay us. Interesting. That's
the the music industry is a comm is
heavily commission based. So, they get
an advance. Yeah. And the label
will the services strike again in making
money. Yeah. Wonderful. So, what I want
to do is reimagine the business in the
simplest format possible that's
organized to make you money both short
and long term. Uhhuh. Is that okay? Yes.
All right. So, I'm going to draw it
across the top here and we're going to
draw it in green because this is the
money path. All right. It's the money
path. You keep your YouTube where it is.
Now, what I want you to do is I want you
to have four different places that
you're going to embed calls to action.
All right? So, number one is at the 30%
mark of every video, I want you to make
a quick 30-se secondond like, "Hey, by
the way, you know, if you want us to,
you know, help you out with your, you
know, music business right now, um, just
DM me on Instagram and I'd love to help
you out. This is my handle." Mhm. Okay.
Number two is the description. All
right? And you want to make sure that
it's above the fold. So, you know, below
this video right now, you'll probably
see two links. One is for people who are
trying to start business, which they go
to school. And if you already have a
business and you're trying to scale and
you have like, you know, a million bucks
a year or more or, you know, 500,000 a
year or more or 10 million a year or
more, uh, you can go to acquisition.com
and, you know, schedule call their team
and see if we can help you out, right?
So, we have a description. Now, on top
of that, pinned comment, so you can own
that real estate. We also have your
profile on YouTube, which gets traffic
as well. And so, those are four places
that we can actually just put and all of
the CTAs here are DM me on Instagram.
Why are we doing that? Because it
already works. So, I'm not trying to
break it. All right. So, now
everything's going to Instagram. So,
instead of having the site, we don't
even care about the site. Who cares?
Doesn't matter. So, we're going to go DM
me on Instagram. And then from there,
what I want you to do is that I want you
to have them book a call without paying.
And then what we're going to do is we're
going to sell them. And what we're going
to do is we're going to sell them a
package. And we're going to sell it to
the outcome. And you're going to say,
"Hey, a lot of lawyers lawyers like to
charge by the hour. The reason that we
don't do that model is because it
disincentivizes us. Our basically our
incentives are adverse to you. When we
do it by the hour, we're incentivized to
take as long as humanly possible. So it
means it cost you more and it takes
longer. That sucks. So what we're going
to do is we're just going to charge you
for the outcome. Period. That's it.
How's that sound? Yeah. So we have to
qualify them before they can go to the
landing page because you know there's 10
million artists on Spotify. Sure. And
only a thousand are professional. Maybe
2,000 are professional. So, do you see
that the landing page? Yeah. But they
all eat, they all have cars, they all
have cell phones, they all pay mortgages
and rent. We're not We don't You sell to
a lot of upandcomers and newcomers.
They're going to use just like you have
been spending your education money that
you make money on this dream that you
have and losing money. We're going to
have them do the same thing. They're
going to take their job money and spend
it on their dream and hopefully they
make it. But our goal isn't to try and
figure out who's going to make it. Our
job is to enable the opportunity. So the
pre-qualification that I would have here
is just income, not like and if you
want, you can add their Spotify if you
think that matters, you know, in the
qualification, but fundamentally. Yeah.
Okay. That's what I figured. So yeah,
because if you I I've worked with
different artists that their Spotify,
for example, I have a Spotify. I'm a
guitar player and I have 15,000 monthly
listeners. But you wouldn't take that to
determine whether I can play you or not.
So income, but we are currently doing it
that way. Yeah, you're right. Yeah,
you're right. So what we're going to do
is income, but we're going to do through
budget, authority, need timing. That's
the the big four, right? So do you have
the money? Is there somebody else who
needs to be on the phone? Your
grandmother, your dog, your your agent,
whatever need. So how important is this
to you? Uh and then timing. If we were
to get you set up, how quickly would you
want us to to make this get this
trademark or get this thing filed?
Right? You want to take the people who
have the money and want to do it now and
are able to make the decision. That's
the qualification. Now, the big the big
question is what are we gonna charge?
So, you're asking me? Yeah. I'm going to
give you a hint. It's more than 250. So,
hopefully the price is right with what
you're going to charge. So, the average
uh ticket on the service size between
the ongoing one time and the
consultation is about 1,500. That's the
average. Okay. And a lot of that is from
people just getting hourly charged. It's
no it's basically the the ongoing right
now is about the the lower ticket is
about a,000 per month. Okay. Where
because we are not uh charging them by
the hour like a traditional lawyer. So
and this is 750 usually. So you can see
that if you combine the other Yeah. They
usually get to So this is what I want
you to do. I would love you to charge
5,000. I feel like that's going to be a
stretch for you emotionally. So, how
about we start at three? Yeah. Can you
do five? We can do five. Can you
emotionally do five? Yeah. We're We're
selling right now three months for
4,000. So, great. So, well then shoot.
Then we might as well do six. Six is the
same as five. Well, you know what? I'll
meet you in the middle. 5,800. Okay. All
right. This is what we're going to sell.
That's your retainer, right? So, either
we can sell So, okay, this is a question
for you. I do I would prefer to sell the
outcome if it's just a clear outcome
that they're they're going for. Um or
you can sell a retainer, right? And just
say like it's 5,800, I'll draw from that
whatever. I prefer outcome personally
because I don't want you to be tied to
hourly if you can if you can afford not
to. You good with that? Yeah, we we can
move towards the outcome if it's the
type of deal that we want to work with.
Like for example, when I say outcome, I
mean like the contracts or the that kind
of thing. Like when it's the
commissionbased stuff, I want the 5,800
plus plus the percentage. That's how
we're doing it right now. Good. We just
need to raise the prices. Okay. And we
also need to organize the business so
that we're optimizing for this outcome,
not three different outcomes and
confusing everybody, right? Okay. Now,
if on the sales call someone is
unqualified, so this depends on your
deal flow, but I'm assuming that you've
got time to take calls. Yeah, because
I'm my time is spread around trying to
understand this. I'm going to help you,
man. All right. We're this this will
work. When you have these people that
are coming the call, what I want to add
is before we have the sell the outcome.
So, this is kind of like on the call
right here beforehand. We're going to
add a VSSL. Okay. So, you're familiar
with a VSSL video sales letter. Do you
have one right now? Um, for the course?
Yes. Okay. So, instead, I just need you
to make one seven minutes, you know,
five to seven minutes. Doesn't need to
be long. Just explaining how you do
things in your process. Okay. And the
other people that you've worked with,
some of the successful outcomes,
reviews, things like that. And then
also, I would set expectations, which is
like on this call, we're going to have
one of two outcomes. um either you want
more personalized attention and we'll
you know give you the outcome that you
want or if you're like just starting out
um we do have an education thing that if
you can't afford our actual services you
can do it on your own so yeah now the
thing is is that you know what I don't
even know if I like that I'm I'm I'm
deleting I'm deleting that okay so the
VSSL is going to sell the services
that's it when you get on the call if
the person lied about their income or
lied about their qualifications which
does happen then you can immediately
triage them and say, "So, Triage doesn't
like you split." Um, and say, "You know
what? Um, you can tell like this isn't
going to be a services sale for $6,000
plus a percentage. Instead, it's going
to be, you know, a one-time uh education
uh product sale, and then you can sell
that." Now, right now, you have this
500, then 500. I'm going to wager that
you don't need like if you're getting
people to buy this in a on a checkout
page, typically you can triple the price
with a phone call of the same thing.
Okay? So you could probably sell for
three grand. So if we're charging six
here, I would say probably somewhere in
the neighborhood of like 2 to 3K is the
right price point for the education
downell. But the only purpose of that is
just so that you can maximize your time
um on the call so that you can still
kind of have something and if you need
to do a payment plan or whatever, you
know what I mean? Like that's that's at
that point you're just trying to
liquidate your time. But fundamentally,
if we were to do this, let's walk
through what it actually looks like. Now
you have your YouTube videos. Now, all
of the calls to action, the way I see my
YouTube is I have, you know, 2,000
video, whatever how many videos I have,
and each of them are basically like
little mini ads that are always running
and underneath of the video or the
quality ad, I have my actual call to
action, and I can I have this surface
area across the whole internet that I
can change and redirect all of that
traffic from all of my videos to
wherever I want. Then you can go back
and on your biggest videos, go get
pinned comments that you know um that
have the same call to action because
some people just read the comments.
Change your profile and then going
forward in your videos, you'll put the
the the CTA towards to DMing on
Instagram. We're going to completely
ignore the site since that's where all
of your all of your sales are happening
on DM. So, let's just push everyone to
DM. Now, how many followers um per month
are you getting? I'm getting about 800
new followers. Guess what we're going to
do? Okay, so this is thing one. thing
too is that for every new follower you
get, I want you to DM them and say, "Are
you here for free content or
entertainment, whatever, entertainment
or you want help?" And then every person
who says they want help is a lead. So
right now, if you think about that, you
got 800 new leads a month that you can
work. Realistically, you close 5% of
those. I mean, it's 40 more sales a
month. At 6K, there's 240. Mhm. That's
just from that. Not including your
existing volume, which we're now going
to redirect everything to the most
efficient monetization model. What stops
you from doing this? Nothing.
Well, I think this will make you a
lot. And I think this will save your
business. And I think this will also
make you very rich. So, we can help more
people. Yeah. Because you can't help
people if you're broke. The thing is is
that the education I think long term
long long term, you might end up just
giving it away for free. Mhm. because
people are coming from that group as
well, I'm assuming. And then they buy
your services. And that's why I'm not
trying to attack this because this is
long-term lead nurture for you. Yeah.
So, where is this hosted?
Kajjabi. Kajjabi. Well, there's your
first mistake. Um, I knew it. No, but if
you if you were to do it on school, um,
there's a couple benefits. The the
biggest one is that we have more active
users than any other group platform um,
and community platform. So like you'll
probably just get people coming into
your community anyways. Mhm. But you can
also every single person who gets into
the group, you can offer a free
onboarding call as a part as a benefit
of being in the community and then you
can use those as setting calls to either
triage them to services or just refer
them to free stuff, right? Like instead
of coming from YouTube, they would come
from the school and then think about it
like this. This is actually be a really
good visual. So your old way, let's do
this in red because Michael loves
colors. Love colors too, Michael. So old
way was this. You had one source of
eyeballs, right? And you were splitting
it between three different places. The
new way is you now have three different
sources of eyeballs and you're forcing
all of them through the most efficient
monetization vehicle because you've got
your YouTube, you've got your Instagram,
and then you've got your group. And all
three of those are pushing to the one
thing that we know makes you the most
money that also people want and we're
pricing it in a way that actually makes
you money. And the question the question
would be so we would create uh from the
in from the DM or the WhatsApp we would
create a calendar link they go there
they'll uh get the the initial
consultation for free is going to be
let's be clear it's not it's not a
consultation it's a sales call. Yeah
it's a sales call. Then from there the
once they schedule the consult the the
call they go to a VSSL to prepare them.
Yes. Yeah. Before the call. Before the
call. Yeah. To prepare them and their
expectations and everything. Then on the
sales call we'll identify uh whether we
can sell them our services or if not
downell them to our course. Exactly.
Right. So our core offer is our the
results, right? The outcome. That's our
core offer. Yeah. And that outcome is
based on your specific need and our
ability to fulfill that. But we're not
saying when people are coming to us
because we're lawyers in this specific
niche. We don't have to talk about
specific outcomes. Uh no, not like you
getting signed with a record label. No,
no. We're going to do the work to
prepare you for that. You're still going
to have to do that on your own. And then
when that deal comes, we ask for 5%. And
the reason we do that is because it
makes it affordable for you at 5,800. If
we didn't charge the percentage and if
you're like, "Oh, I don't want to pay
that percentage." Then you can pay us
25,000. So, we'll do 25,000 without the
percentage or we'll do 5,800 with the
percentage. Got it. Got it. And then,
uh, do you think that that also gives
you a very nice price anchor? Yeah, it
makes it makes sense because, uh, the
the percentage right now, the last two
deals, the average has been like 40
something K. Okay. And the the lead
magnet would be the sales call. Yeah. I
I want to just do this as the easiest
like what is the easiest thing that I
can do to immediately fix this business
and make it profitable. Okay, if we
wanted to add something else, we could,
but I just don't want to right now.
Okay, we're going from spraying the
traffic all over the place into places
that lose money to pointing three
different places to the one place that
makes money and doing more of what
already works. And we're just going to
add a little bit of qualification, add a
little VSSL, fix the pricing, and then
we're also going to route all the new
followers that come there, too. So,
you're going to have a you will likely
have a lot of opportunities. So, you'll
likely be taking five, you know, 8 10 12
sales calls a day. Okay. And which is a
good thing. It's No, it's great. And I
have three people that can actually do
that with me. So, if everyone has their
own calendar link as you explain in your
book, then Mhm. Okay. I have a book. I'm
the bestselling author in Spanish in
this niche. Okay. How do you where do
you see that fitting in? Maybe that's a
lead magnet like giving it out for free
like you do because they usually become
super fans like Yeah, of course. Yeah.
Um or is that just another So there's a
couple So there's I would say like right
off the top of my head there's two
places that we could like if you wanted
to use it now I would say that you could
give it to people who are unqualified.
If you don't think you could like if you
look at somebody's profile and you don't
think they're they look like I mean you
can probably tell if somebody's not
qualified. Um, you could say, "Hey, um,
it doesn't look like you're ready for
our level of services, but because I
want to, you know, invest in the
relationship longterm, here's a copy of
my book." I think that would be a very
elegant way to not overly complexify
what already will work. Long term, we
could start using it as a um, a way that
we would drive traffic in the future.
And then you could have a call team call
the people who bought the book and then
see if they're, you know, they want more
help and then you could basically bring
it would just we all we would do is we
add as another circle. But right now you
have three more than sufficient traffic
sources that you were just wildly
undermonetizing
and we just need to fix that. Okay. And
the last question would be um on the
software side. Yeah. Because the product
road map is almost finished entirely
with all of the features that the
companies are looking for. Yeah. If I'm
not investing any energies on that, I
want to know. I'll believe that when I
see it. Okay. Okay. So if I'm not
suppose I'm not spending energy in a in
a world that doesn't exist. Yes. Yeah.
Suppose that in fantasy land. Is there a
way that we can create like a sunset
period where we would say okay I'm going
to give the team x amount of time to
roll out all of the features that these
companies that are saying I want to use
it. I'm going to pay for it. You know 15
$25,000 per year for the software. Is
there a way to create that while we're
focusing on this? So at the very
beginning, you know, I said like what do
you what do you want, right? And so we
had to fix making this make money
because you're going to run out of
money. Yes. And so we have to solve
that. The thing that makes me hesitate
with the software is the amount of work
and the amount of expertise it takes to
make software really work is really
high. Mhm. And so I would be more
inclined to say like if you have some of
these big companies, you might just give
them the software or have them just say
like you're like, "Hey, instead of
25,000 a year, if you just pay me 100
grand or pay me 200 grand, I'll just
give you the whole thing." And that's
basically you getting it at cost and
saving two years and then you can focus
on this. Got it. That's of course if you
want to make money. Of course. No, no,
no. I understand. I just want to have
like the different scenarios. Yeah. I
mean, the alternative scenario is that
you burn the education, you burn the
services to the ground, you go all in on
the software, and you need to be able to
fund that loss for a while and then
actually build it, right? No. If that
doesn't seem like it's a that's too more
fantasy than reality, then you learned a
ton of lessons, which is fine. Everybody
just gets better from learning and you
build a really good business, which I
think you have all the makings. You
literally have everything in place. They
were just organized wrong. That's the
good news is like I don't we don't have
to build anything. We just have to take
what we already had, redirect it through
a better monetization vehicle and that's
it. And so you like this is the first
step. We add traffic here as the second
step and then we'll add the book as the
third step later. But for now, you just
need to step one and step two. We have
enough leads to probably fill up your
calendar plus one other person, maybe
two. And if you have three people
selling full-time and you have a $6,000
thing, you could be at $18,000 a day,
$30,000 a day, $50,000 a day. And the
next problem that's going to hit you is
that you're not going to have the team
to actually deliver on this stuff, which
we'll cross later. But that's what this
is going to do. This is going to break
the business, but you'll be making
money. And then we'll take that money
that we're making, and then we'll solve
the thing that's broken, which is that
we're going to hire more augalos. So
we're getting Spanish for lawyer.
Yeah. You're doing it right. So I'm
giving you a little Puerto Rican Spanish
there.
So our constraint right now on your
framework on the scaling workshop Yeah.
is demand. Is demand. Yeah, because
we're not only uh starting and stopping,
but also we're not directing them
through the proper channels and you were
mispriced. So you So I have uh my little
my little moniker for the six big
mistakes that small business owners
make. So let's make those in red. And I
think you were making almost all of
them, which is great. The good thing is
it's only up from here. Yeah. So you
were selling to too many different
avatars. So that's number one. Focus,
which is that you had more than one
business. So you were you were hitting
that one. You're hitting this one. Um
you you weren't so overexpansion. Uh
which I will not say that you were
wrong. So we put it under focus. I'll
give you a neutral on that one. Put it
there to be aware. Uh-huh. Then we have
compensation. So it's are you overpaying
your people, which right now I don't get
that impression. Underpriced, which you
were, or mispriced. So you had that one.
And then this one is single product. So,
that's when somebody has a front end and
a back end, which I'll say that you had
kind of like a half issue. We had the
the $250, you know, per hour uh service
fee, but we didn't have the kind of
percentage win rate yet, and it wasn't
part of a standard offer. So, I'll say
that you had like a half a little X, a
little mini X, okay, there. But the good
news is that these are the mistakes that
most small business owners make and it's
normal and it's okay and that's why
we're fixing it. And the next phase to
to have a timeline or at least to be
aware of our next phase would be do this
until we get to a million per month. Is
that your I don't know if you'll get to
a million a month from this. You will
certainly make a lot more than you are
now. And the next thing that's going to
break is you're going to run out of
lawyers. So the next issue you're going
to run into is supply constraint. I
actually think you have probably more
demand. Like you will not be able to
sell through the demand that you already
have without expanding supply. But if we
completely utilize your existing supply
of, you know, work that you could do at
the appropriate price, you could
absolutely make this into a
multi-million dollar per year business.
Yeah. It's just becoming a a law firm,
you know, a bigger law firm. Yeah. And a
specialized law firm, which is good. So,
you have that niche down. You have a
very specific niche. And there's nice
thing is that there's a lot of people
who want this service. And the price
point that we're charging is an
appropriate price for somebody who's,
you know, wanting to make a bet on
themselves in their career. You have to
make an investment just like you do.
They have to make an investment, too.
Yeah. And that number is that um the
$5,000 is that for any type of outcome?
No. I mean, you'll know this better than
I do, but I just want to make sure that
you know uh the average ticket. Mhm. I
want to I want to make sure that I'm
running at at least 80% gross margins
for service minimum. So, your actual
cost, so your actual cost on this should
be, let's see, should it should be less
than call it like 1,200 bucks or I'll
say 1,100. So, if you're less than
$1,100 in terms of total cost uh for
this to deliver that to deliver that,
then you can then you charge 5,800. And
so, I'm guessing your man hours are
going to cost you less. I mean, I don't
know what you pay your your lawyers, but
let's say it's $100 an hour. If it's
less than 11 hours to do it, then you're
good to go. And if they do it in five,
amazing. Okay. So, if I've had the cost,
for example, a lawyer cost me x amount
per month, now I know that I need to be
making five times more. Five times more
minimum. Okay. And that may sound crazy
to anybody who's listening to this who
doesn't have a business, but let me let
me show you a visual. So good. So good.
This is great. People say that, but
let's imagine we have $100 of revenue to
keep this simple. If you have a 20%
gross uh sorry, uh 20% cost, but 80%
gross margin business, then it's like,
cool. So we already have $20 gone. So we
have $80 left. But we're still going to
have marketing that we got to spend.
Mhm. We're going to still have admin
costs, uh, you know, uh, people who are
scheduling and all that stuff. We have
sales, um, that we're going to have to
pay on top of that. And that's going to
be the majority for this business
because the the labor is going to be
here, right, in terms of your cost of
goods. And so maybe all of these things
cost, you know, 60%. Right? So then we
still have a 20% margin in the business.
But that sounds greedy when you're like,
"Oh my god, there's 80." It's like,
yeah, but we got to do all the other
costs out of 80 and then whatever's left
is our profit. Now hopefully you can run
this thing at 30, right? And then you
have a 50% margin here which would be
wonderful and we smile.
Got it. So all in all we went from sad
face to smiley face. Did it great. I was
aware that services was the the play
when we focus on services this year and
we're already making way more money. But
that was you already 4x the business
just by focusing on that one thing. And
that's with still having the
distraction. Like you absolutely can be
at multiple millions a year. Like no
question. Given the fact that you have a
90,000 YouTube following, you have a
23,000 person Instagram following. You
have a community of people who love you
and are raving fans. You have all of the
foundation. So the good news is that all
the work that you spent doing over the
last however many years was not wasted.
You just didn't monetize it well. And
the good news is you can do it now. So
no big deal. What's the role of for
example now that we're getting
invitations to go and speak to other
countries? What do you think about that
from the focus side? Is that something
for distribution? Like because if no
other lawyers are doing that, no other
lawyers are publishing their books, is
that something that we can use to
differentiate from other particularly in
service- based businesses? It's a good
question. It's a tough call and the
reason for that is that it's a it's for
sure a long-term investment uh to speak
on stages and things like that. The
thing is is that you're currently not
demand constrained. So you speaking on
stages will just generate more demand
that you can't handle. Let's play it out
the other way. If you speak on stages
and you take your eye off the ball in
the business, you lose. If you focus on
the business and you continue to grow
the firm, the stages still be there
because you'll just be bigger. So that
is why maybe the counterargument would
be if you want us to go to the stage,
you have to pay us an amount that it's
worth it. It's worth it. If you know you
that you generate three sales a day at
$6,000 when you're there and it takes
you two days, then your speaking fee is
said $36,000 plus travel. Exactly. You
already have the number because you have
it on a dayto-day basis. Yeah. And also
to be fair, the opportunity cost isn't
just what you what money you would have
made, but also the focus and the
distraction that takes away as well. So
there's hard cost and soft cost. The
hard cost is you really just won't make
these six sales. The soft cost is what
else would you have done in between and
then not had to deal with any of this
hassle. Perfect. Will you do this? Yes.
All right. Deal. Done.